[Musik]
herzlich willkommen servicewelt ich
glaube dieses video haben sich viele von
euch gewünscht denn heute gibt es die
harry potter torte und ihr seht schon
ich bin vor dem harry potter fieber ich
hab den dumbledore zauberstab
ich habe einen schal ich wollte
eigentlich in anderen schade aber der
war morath zu teuer also hat minute
mitgebracht passt zwar nicht so im
outfit aber er hält meinen hals warm
heute machen die torte und ich bin schon
gespannt darauf ob sie euch gefällt es
war ich zuerst einmal einen kuchenteig
und da habe ich mir überlegt nehmen wir
ein kuchenteig ich habe jetzt mal was
neues zusammengestellt mit malzbier das
ist natürlich alkoholfrei und harry
potter hat doch immer dieses butterbier
vanille josch sachs war es nicht ja
solchen sachs irgendwas butterbier
geschmack im film egal wie auch immer
ich hab mir gedacht das passt einfach
gut dazu also machen wir das jetzt also
für den kuchenteig verwende ich fünf
eier 250 gramm zucker eine prise salz
etwas wandel extract 250 gramm malzbier
100 gramm sonnenblumenöl 150 gramm
joghurt das ist der dreieinhalb
prozentige 280 gramm mehl zweieinhalb
teelöffel backpulver 100 gramm kakao und
170 km mandeln die werde ich jetzt
gleich noch malen
ich glaube ich behalt diesem zauberstab
und mache jetzt jedes video damit wie
sein lehrer starb kann ich mal kurz
seine brille haben schade eigentlich
denn so eine harry potter brille volkan
wie kannst du ohne brille überhaupt
sehen oh mein gott dann wird sogleich
schwindlig ich glaube ich habe gute
augen und du nicht okay ich habe jetzt
ganz kurz in der küchenmaschine wird die
mandeln kurz zerkleinern und dann
verliere ich den teig
die id sind zimmer warm denn zimmer war
mayer lassen sich besser aufschlagen
deswegen habe ich auch immer so einfach
wo ich einfach die eier am lagere
die dürfen ja auch bei raumtemperatur
gelagert werden und wenn sie mal nicht
immer warm sind wenn ihr kühlschrank
kante gehabt dann legte die eier mit
schale einfach in warmes wasser nicht in
kochendes und dann werden sie ganz
schnell zimmer war
hier kommt jetzt der zucker dazu mit dem
salz vanille extrakt immer gut
durchschütteln und jetzt einfach die
maschine für etwa fünf bis sieben
minuten rühren lassen bis die eier masse
richtig schaurig ist's ein kleiner jetzt
in der zwischenzeit auch schon mal die
mandeln
das mache ich jetzt ganz gut hier ihr
kennt doch direkt gemahlin nehmen aber
ganze mandeln sind einfach sehr
aromatisch deswegen habe ich am liebsten
so hier an
und verteilung
jetzt ist die eier zucker wasser richtig
schön cremig ich kann jetzt hier schon
mal die trockenen zutaten verrühren
also mehl und backpulver die zutaten
werden gleich gesiebt damit nicht klumpt
hier kann ich jetzt schon mal die
flüssigen zutaten eine maß bier und auch
den joghurt der macht den kuchen richtig
schön saftig nur ganz kurz einrühren
ein niedriger stufe und dann kommen
jetzt die trockenen zutaten dazu hier
noch die mandeln dazu und jetzt wird der
teig wirklich nur noch ganz kurz
verrührt denn sobald mehr drin ist
solltet ihr nur kurz rühren damit der
kuchen nicht speckig wird also kurz und
nur bei niedriger stufe
der teig ist relativ flüssig daher
schlage ich jetzt den bug ring ein
und da ist es echt am besten wenn ihr so
ein präpariertes papier habe vom
backpapier das hat einfach ein bisschen
besser halt ich halte zählen ring mit
der anderen hand klappt ich den teig
außen herum
das war die ausnahme
und das müsst ihr aber wirklich nur
machen wenn der teig ganz flüssig ist
damit er nicht ausläuft
ansonsten bei bis mittag zum beispiel
braucht es nicht nur kurz kontrollieren
das alles berührt ist fühle ich den teig
hier ein am rand streiche ich ihnen ein
bisschen hoch so backt er gleichmäßiger
durch und dann kommt doch schon in den
vorgeheizten backofen und ich kann dir
da zwischenzeit schon mal erdbeeren aus
dem gefrierfach im topf einfach so ein
bisschen einkochen lassen
das brauche ich nämlich für die krim
für die kuchen bremen nehme ich jetzt
erdbeeren aus dem tiefkühlfach der mich
bereits auftauen lassen und tief
gefrorene früchte sind wirklich super
zum einen bekommt er sie zu jeder saison
und sie werden wirklich ganz reif
geerntet und erntefrisch sofort
eingefroren
also haben die wirklichen super
geschmack die sind wie gesagt bereits
aufgetaucht muss jetzt auch an der
flüssigkeit und jetzt werde ich sich
jetzt das stampfen und dann so lange
einkochen lassen bis fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr vorhanden ist damit
einfach das ganze wasser verkocht und
verdunstet und ich nur noch diesen
kuchen edberg geschmack es gebe es hier
auch schon mal zitronensaft dazu zum
einen für die säure und zum anderen dass
die erdbeeren schon rot bleiben und
nicht bräunlich werden
und jetzt wie gesagt einfach nur auf
kochen immer wieder umrühren schön
durchführen und so besitzt das stampfen
und einfach so lange bis die flüssigkeit
fast weg ist
der kuchen ist jetzt gebacken
das papier habe ich jetzt auch schon
abkühlen lassen und jetzt brauche ich
hier noch weitere zutaten für die creme
und zwar 250 g weiche butter 150 gramm
puderzucker etwas wandel extrakt 450
gramm frischkäse und grüne verpasste es
soll zuerst hat man hier den tortenring
raus lösen hätten kuchen aus dem
tortenring lösen das meine ich doch
[Musik]
backpapier unterwegs dann den ring weg
und jetzt halt wäre ich den kuchen
einmal eine person arbeitet in bakken
kocht weiß und alle stehen nur um ihre
arbeit auch und hier was ist mit euch
krisensitzung was ist los und schneiden
noch mal da ist
ich rette die welt stelle ich kurz zur
seite und kann mich jetzt um die creme
kümmern
nämlich die weiche butter das ist
wirklich so ein bisschen amerikanisch
angehauchte das rezept dann etwas
vanille extrakt puderzucker und jetzt
kann ich die masse richtig schön cremig
verrühren
jetzt wirklich bei drei bis vier minuten
schön rühren
jetzt gebe ich hier langsam den
frischkäse dazu soll das war's jetzt
erst mal und davon nehme ich mir jetzt
ein bisschen was raus so etwa 100 gramm
und in den rest kommt jetzt das
erdbeerpüree die erdbeer creme ist schon
mal fertig und hier nehme ich jetzt ein
bisschen grüne verpasste ganz hell nur
so kein schönes grünen werden sondern
ganz blass grill und das hier verrühren
und die creme sitzen bis hin zu fester
kommen jetzt ein paar tropfen milch dazu
damit sie etwas flüssiger wird ich glaub
spätestens jetzt wissen die harry potter
fans was ich mache
oder ich glaube schon dass völlig die
grüne masse in einen spritzbeutel und da
habe ich eine kleine loch teile drauf zu
schreiben und kann jetzt hier diese
torte zusammensetzen nämlich eine dreh
platte ist einfach hier ein bisschen
rosa creme
ihr könnt auch marmelade nehmen zum
füllen dann kommt der zweite boden drauf
wieder etwas creme und der decke jetzt
könnt ihr die gesamte torte mit der rest
sind creme bestreichen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich muss jetzt an der stelle
sagen was ich mache wenn ich david ort
jetzt nicht klappt streifen das wird
nämlich die geburtstagstorte die hecke
mit harry mitgebracht hat und die war
nicht klappt also die darf nicht perfekt
sein
also muss ich dir zum perfekt machen
[Musik]
dort hatte ich geschrieben papa lass
doch nicht einfach ist
ja ich mache es einfach so gut ich es
kann oder wird sie schon okay hier schon
noch creme ok und die muss jetzt einfach
drauf streichen
ja ich hätte einfach von anfang an dich
machen lassen sollen wir bauen doch
drucker war die creme geholt volker sich
jetzt langsam vielleicht viel zu gut für
den kopf habe ich mal erzählt das ist dj
war
nein du hast du gesehen hast du da bist
ja perfekt so muss es sein danke sagen
ich habe schon so das bedürfnis torten
immer glatt zu streichen aber die muss
so ok und jetzt und ich brauche die
vorlage damit es auch falsch schreiben
sich auch falsch geschrieben sein ihre
papas nicht gemacht weil ich muss auch
diesen refrain machen so ich glaube es
einfacher den riss danach hin zu machen
ich mache es so ich probier's mal okay
ich so originalgetreu wie möglich
da hat er erst sr gemacht und hat es
dann nämlich das eh vergessen und vater
sind so hier eingesetzt und ja ich komme
auch er ist reine zwischen pte hier ist
auch noch sowieso hätte auch so gar
nicht so einfach so hier ist eure harry
potter torte auf die ihr so lange
gewartet habt ich habe mein versprechen
endlich eingelöst
shakira jetzt packen wir die noch in den
karton so wie es im original auch ist
ich hab da mal was vorbereitet glaub ich
wollte schon immer mal sagen sie sind
fernseh koch kocht nicht selber frauen
sagt dann hat jetzt einfach da rein mehr
vorkommen soll mit karton gut
samir ait kampfjets zu harry potter
bringen
[Musik]
kommst du ich hab was für dich
zwischen graue strähnen happy birthday
harry da stehe ich jetzt selbst
übertroffen so nicht schlecht gekommen
von mir noch nicht sagen hauptsache
schlägt oder ja ne jetzt haben es die
zuschauer wollten unbedingt nach harry
potter torte los hier habt ihr die
original harry potter torte sagt sie
weiß ja auch wie man manchmal hauptsache
angriff macht ob max probieren ja ich
probiere natürlich versuchen wir wollten
eigentlich sogar die szene nachspielen
das heck wird kommt die tür so aufstößt
okay aber passiert sind und da kriegt
die torte und dann sagt hack mit harry
dass er den zauberer ist auch in dem
dänen mit nach hogwarts
er weiß ja nun über hinweis ich hoffe
jetzt bitten dass die torte richtig cool
ist ich mache das ja von cola gamer auf
seine party zu gehen und sagen ob die
geräte überhaupt gebacken
da kommt so was aber ich das foto hätte
man das ist jetzt hier drin
ich hoffe einfach dass ich 40
kaputtmachen gut doch ok dann lasst dann
gleich noch fotos machen aber ich habe
mir bei der erfüllung echt mühe gegeben
ich glaube dass mir helfen ohne spaß mir
ist es wichtig das ist
darf ich probiert kann dieses stück
bitte nicht ganz auf essen weil wir
selber fotografieren ist auch gut für
den blutdruck cholesterin und die habe
ich jetzt
hammer saftig schokolade isst er die
gastrolle tony scholes
macht er sie mit seinem guten privaten
und sagt mir was unglaublich gemacht ihr
werdet menschen kommt in erscheinung was
ist aber wenn sie es dann essen vor der
sich vielleicht noch mal kurz was
auflösen und lasse ich bin heute ist der
erste april
und ich habe jetzt drei tage an der
harry potter tore gearbeitet also nicht
an der liebe gott sagen dass ich mich
drei jahre beim world of harry potter
gruppe also bis heute als erste auf den
scherz aber ist echte kunde torte
geworden und vor allem wenn ich nicht
gedacht dass ich sie doch so kurzer
schlechthin krieg also richtig aufregen
nach wird getreu mit dem
rechtschreibfehlern und versteht auch zu
essen und am sonntag kommt die richtige
harry potter motiv torte auf dem portal
ja da habe ich wirklich den sprechenden
hut gleis 9 drei viertel dann noch eine
harry potter logo torte also da können
wir wirklich gespannt darauf sein wie
lego harry potter oder weil wir wissen
sind wir wissen es nicht hier sein
das könnte sein also schaltet unbedingt
am sonntag noch immer ein
denn da gibt es eine richtige motiv
torte und probiert diese torte auf jeden
fall aus abgesehen super einfach super
schnell gemacht und schmeckt auch super
lecker wir sind ganz tolle kurven
es komme oft auch äußere des weges
überhaupt geheiratet im inneren werte
zählen zum beispiel mein papa damals
gesagt hat wir sind sowohl hat damals
unser bad repariert und renoviert und
dann hat er seine braune silikon bogen
gemacht und eigentlich hatten wir graue
fließen um eine heiße papa das sieht
doch gar nicht schön aus ohne haar
wachsen
wir sind dynamisch ich glaube sagt dich
damit gemeint das auge gewöhnt sich als
hässlichen zurückgeht ist so war immer
ganz leicht ist er mich und das hat man
nie auf kamera und wenn ich ihn zurück
liste weil ich mich einfach nur wäre und
verteidigung welche über den hammers und
dann haben als auf kamera und denken
immer alle ich ich greife ihn einfach
anfangen dabei verträge gehen so je
gehört habe und dass humor ist das salz
in der suppe des humor und jede und
jeder der auf verheiratet ist weiß genau
wie sie es mal zum indischen markt wenn
sie glück nicht erst am tag und schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare wer diese
partie findet ja ich bin sehr cool und
macht es einfach mal nach er wollte man
eine einfache torte hat prof
der ist den ganzen kuchen aufwärmen
nichts mehr für die worte ich finde die
ganze woche auf mich
entschuldigung seht ihr was war das nur
für trainer ist hat die gabel gewaschen
[Musik]